que faire en cas de piqûre de méduse
certains prétendent qu'il faut faire
pipi dessus absolument pas c'est une
idée reçue diffusée entre autres par la
série Friends dans les années 1990 le
malentendu vient du fait que l'urine est
chaude et qu'elle apaise momentanément
la douleur en réalité faire pipi sur une
piqûre plutôt sur une brûlure de Méduse
le même s'avérer dangereux urine peut
faire éclater les cnidocides ce sont les
cellules globuleuses et urticantes
laissées par la méduse ce qui peut
entraîner une surinfection il est plus
judicieux de rincer votre plaie avec de
l'eau de mer pour retirer les cellules
urticantes incrustées dans la peau on
peut utiliser la tranche d'une carte
bancaire par exemple vous pouvez aussi
frotter avec du sable mais en cas de
grosses douleurs n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre chez un médecin ou chez un
pharmacien